se llama el dientón ying y tiene 24 años
trabajaba en un restaurante será
recordado como el primer condenado por
la ley de seguridad nacional del hong
kong el joven ha sido declarado culpable
esta tarde de los delitos de incitación
a la secesión y terrorismo y los
próximos días se dará a conocer su
condena que podría alcanzar la cadena
perpetua la sentencia condenatoria se
daba por descontado porque los hechos se
habían quedado grabados en unas imágenes
que dieron la vuelta al mundo el joven a
bordo de una motocicleta de gran
cilindrada arrollo a los tres policías
que intentaban detenerle y les causó
graves heridas así que el debate
jurídico se centraba en la bandera que
estaba llevando en esos momentos
en la que se leía liberación con la
revolución de nuestros días uno de los
eslóganes más célebres de las protestas
violentas del año anterior el tribunal
ha sentado que se abandera incitaba a la
secesión uno de los delitos más
según la nueva ley bajo esa ley aprobada
por pekín hace 13 meses se ha detenido a
138 personas y se han presentado cargos
sobre 76 así que es más que probable que
en los próximos meses veamos un caudal
de duras sentencias condenatorias